we've been asking for news on the game
and many of us have said even tiny
updates would suffice and well that's
exactly what we have today a tiny bit of
hogwarts legacy news directly from a wb
source there are also some hints out
there that even bigger news could be on
the horizon and possibly soon and i'll
definitely make sure to cover that too
before we wrap up the video today
retrorecontour here and today this news
update comes to us from the toy world
magazine rachel wakeley a warner
brothers gm did a little q a with the
magazine where they ask her some general
questions about what's going on with the
latest wizarding world projects and what
harry potter fans can expect in 2022 and
beyond if you're a harry potter fan it's
honestly all worth a read but for those
primarily concerned with hogwarts legacy
here's the relevant bit of info and i
should also point out this was actually
about two weeks ago that this interview
first surfaced and i kind of waited for
it a bit hoping there might be more to
come but alas just a tiny morsel of info
for us muggles at least for now so if
you take a look at this piece the
hogwarts legacy bit comes with the
second question which reads quote what
new developments are coming through for
2022 and then you can go and read a
little bit into the answer where wakely
says quote as for new content we have
two major releases a film and a game
that will be sure to generate incredible
excitement amongst fans let me interject
here and say yes we're excited now
please more info she goes on to say the
first is the film release of fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore now
announced to be releasing on the 8th of
april in the uk close quote and then a
bit later quote the second major release
of 2022 will be for a new console game
hogwarts legacy close quote and before
you panic yes it's still coming to pc as
well there's a lot more she goes on to
say about hogwarts legacy so we'll get
to that but i want to stop here briefly
because there are two different ways
people are interpreting what she says
even here from the beginning some are
taking this to mean that hogwarts legacy
will definitely be releasing after
fantastic beasts whereas others are
saying no hold up she's just saying it's
the second major release but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's releasing
after fantastic beasts well you want my
opinion here i think this is a carefully
crafted answer so we would have exactly
what's happening would happen where
people aren't really sure what's being
said here to me i think the answer is
very intentionally vague on the
specifics of when the game will come out
chances are she doesn't even know the
actual release date yet so you want to
be very careful that you don't comment
on something here and then have to
backtrack later on and even if she
actually does know she'll obviously want
to protect the release date as that
hasn't been made official just yet so
that's my take on it i think it's meant
to be ambiguous i don't really think it
matters either way though personally i
do think the game is releasing after
fantastic beasts simply because of how
close we already are to 2022. as for the
rest of the quote there's quite a bit
here that honestly as a fan has me super
excited if i wasn't excited enough
already wakeley says quote the reaction
to the trailer for this has been amazing
and it looks set to be a huge success we
know that gaming is such an important
part of the market and one that we had
to be involved in and then here's the
big line from what we've seen the launch
will be well worth the wait and deliver
a unique way for fans to interact with
the franchise close quote now yes of
course she works for wb she's not going
to say something negative about the game
but if they had seen something behind
closed doors that was some big reason
for concern or if the game was in major
trouble then they just wouldn't say
anything at all the fact that she speaks
directly and confidently about the game
should really encourage us as fans i
mean honestly it does for me at the
start of the video i mentioned some
hints that more news could be on the way
soon well it just so happens that
supposed hogwarts legacy insider milly a
tweeted an image of the game with a
tweet that simply reads soon how soon i
guess we'll have to wait and see if you
missed it there was actually another
recent rumor that the hogwarts legacy
release date had been leaked as part of
an nvidia data breach i have a full
video covering that story and i'll link
to it here on the left side of your
screen now as always thank you all so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon